this is the first time I've been on an
are you afraid of the dark set in awhile
yeah so you're giving me a tour I want
you to tell me what we're looking at
because it looks pretty scary it feels
pretty scary in here well first of all
welcome back thank you appreciate it so
this is Rachel's nightmare you have a
dream about a creepy carnival and now
the carnival is real
so this stage the stage in racial
nightmare where mr. top-hat comes out on
the stage just thinking of mr. top-hat
please be kind of scared I know it's
it's gonna be really really awesome now
we're gonna go downstairs and we'll show
you the tunnel the tunnel the tunnel the
tunnel the tunnel let's go
this is the opening shot of the show and
yeah it's vaguely Rachel running down
this tunnel being chased by mr. top-hat
water stripping it's very spooky yeah
very scary I'm honored to be I mean
bringing something like this back to
life submitted for the approval of the
midnight society I call this story in a
carnival of tip its are you afraid of
the dark so obviously you're gonna get
scared sometimes do you have some fun on
the set with some of the other cast
members as I know I did that back in the
day we have I mean we've done a lot of
the campfire stuff already it's looking
amazing and we have a few things that
I'm not really allowed to talk about but
it'll be it'll be really cool the
carnival is coming to town this weekend
this is the same carnival from my story
your fear of clowns whoo where'd this
come from because there were a lot of
clowns in the initial are you afraid of
the dark and I hear that there are gonna
be clowns in this version too
I'm really scared honestly because I
think there's gonna be a lot of them and
they're gonna look super creepy Rachel
I'm afraid of something what are you
afraid of what can fans expect I think
what's really exciting about this
iteration is it came out first in the
early 90s nothing like it existed in the
space and so the idea of fear for young
kids was something that Nick at night
was introducing and then there's been
20-some odd years of people raising the
bar and raising the bar and raising the
bar on that what kind of scary works and
what what gets kids really excited and
so now I love that that are you afraid
of the dark is to come back in having
all these other people sort of raise the
bar and raise the bar and set a new bar
for what that looks like
I thought you liked being scared the
first shot of the show is actually here
so I thought we would end our interview
it's come full circle
clucks so we don't have a bucket we
don't know or campfire or campfire
it doesn't matter we've got the care of
our kids our friendship and that's what
the Messiah is so I declare this meeting
of Canada easy camp and to do in that
society clubs
I find who did it us all right okay
let's get out of here I'm scared